all right Emmanuel yes Emmanuel where'd
you grow up where'd you were you from
originally I was born in the very
southern tip of Louisiana
um
down in the swamps we traveled more by
boat and car is
I was exercised through demon possession
at age of four really yeah it was a
heavy heavy uh it was you know
kind of like Eastern Europe it was very
rural there's a lot of superstition and
my stepfather
he uh his mom and aunts were very very
Catholic like the black lace around the
hair and everything
and I was having these incredible
stomach pains that couldn't be explained
they kept taking me to the doctor
and uh couldn't figure it out plus I was
having these unbelievable nightmares and
for a kid that age I would wake up
screaming and describe these horrific
scenes that I could only describe as
like kind of Genghis kongish like these
Raiders on horses going in and just
who rate killing everyone slaughtering
people in these Villages and I'd wake up
and tell this to my mom and
they were all freaked out because why is
a little kid have these images and these
brutal images and the thing is in the in
in the dreams I was part of it it was
like I was living it so anyway they kept
I kept waking up from this and they
tried doctor after doctor and they
couldn't figure anything out so they
wanted my stepfather's mother and Aunt
suggested an exorcism
and at the time I was being I was being
raped brutally by an uncle
and uh I believed that I mean I believed
for you for a long time that the raping
of a child put a demon in him so in my
mind I was kind of convinced that that's
what was going on but uh they took me to
a trailer
I remember it very clearly deep in the
swamps it was like a short trailer and a
man came out and he was really really
tall and skinny very very tall and he
had he was an albino
or if you gave them it seemed like he
was an albino he had white hair very
pale his eyes were odd he was wearing a
button-down blue shirt and tan pants
like Dockers I thought that was very odd
for the the exorcism man but he took
they had me in his trailer and they
started pouring garlic tea down me just
like tons of garlic tea just very harsh
and he was bending me all these strange
positions and drawing with garlic
crosses all over my body and speaking
like what I would call tongues now
but just constantly and contorting me
and towarding me and this went on for a
long time and the women were sitting in
the corner praying and doing the Rosary
and my mom was sitting in the corner
looking kind of suspicious of the whole
thing and then when he sent me home he
sent me home with uh
I had to drink two cups two cloves of
garlic tea a day
for I think three months or six months
or something I can't remember exactly
but uh the dream oh the dream stopped
and the stomach pain slowly went away
and everybody was amazed by it but I
thought about it years later because my
my stepdad came back from Nam psycho
he was very heavily decorated he got
shot three times carrying a guy from
behind Emily line Enemy Lines who had
been shot six times he saved that man's
life he got awarded decked out and sent
home came home a complete psycho violent
violent beat my mom tortured us
but um he hated me my brother because we
weren't as real kids and he used to tie
us to the back of the boat on a link for
rope and just drag us through the water
that was kind of so he didn't have to
put up with us we loved it we thought it
was the greatest thing in the world but
I thought about it
you're in that Bayou Water get in your
mouth and your gut parasites stomach
pain I was saying later on I was like
garlic what would garlic tea do with
Chase parasites out of the body so I
came up with a kind of a devil's
advocate answer to the situation myself
but yeah that was early on Louisiana but
I was like kind of my introduction to
pain and uh there was a lot of pain but
uh I think the garlic tea was an
introduction to curing pain how would
you describe your childhood in general
uh
a series of molestations and beatings
with moments of uh of painful clarity
I was a very serious kid my aunts and
uncles said I was never a kid all the
pictures you see me I'm like very stoic
and
very like brooding looking
I was there was a lot of violence uh I
was a Miss I was Misfit people didn't
like me
um
when I moved from Texas
back to Texas my mom was from Texas and
her and her two best friends were
graduating we're headed to Miami that
was their big trip but they saw a sign
that said Grand Isle of the Miami of
Louisiana and they went down there and
they all ended up working the same
bowling alley and Pregnant
and uh
that's why I'm here but um we moved back
to Texas we escaped him in the middle of
the night um he when he came back from
Nam he took a job he was a tugboat
captain that took supplies out to the to
the oil
um
the the big stands out there I forget
what you call them but uh so he was 12
days on 12 days off those 12 days off
were great it was like living in the
swamps Tom Sawyer running around I I had
little Shacks I built in the swamps I
would sleep out there all the time but
um
when he was in it was a living hell
torture all the time so anyway we fled
from him in the middle of the night went
to Texas and we were very poor like
really poor my mom worked three jobs we
ate oatmeal for months
um and I had like I said I had an uncle
that was raping me and later I found out
he was raping my brother I didn't know
that at the time and other members of
the family
but he was brutally raping me and it put
this deep weird guilt complex in me that
I thought I was to blame for some
some reason
I think probably a lot of kids too
it's a horrible thing to go through
um yeah the weird thing though is I was
really aware when I was a kid like like
Ultra wear and I didn't tell anybody one
reasons I didn't tell anybody is I
thought my aunts and uncles would think
all gay people
were pedophiles which isn't the case so
I literally when ears would have never
mentioned it
yeah and then I'd see him and As I Grew
Older I built resentment towards them
when I was younger I don't know I felt
with the guilt over well me but later I
started realizing
sorry that it wasn't my
what killed me though is when I found
out it was happening to my brother
that maybe I'll get stopped if I decided
something and my cousins and stuff which
is a lot to carry
anyway but uh it was uh you know there
was great parts of my childhood I was uh
all that pain and stuff fed into my
heart
from day one I was drawing and painting
my teachers let me stay in from pee and
paint and jaw and I started playing
guitar at seven
and I fell in love with rock music I saw
the Osmonds put his Livestock Show and
Rodeo and I saw this team of girls
jumped the fence run through knocked
Securities down get up and doing great
crazy horses still Donny Osmond's shoe
and then they grabbed him and they ran
right past me and there was these young
really attractive young girls and I was
like eight or something and they jumped
back out of the Astrodome over the
railing right by me and ran up and I
thought that's what I wanted
whatever makes girls do that
is what I want to do and that's what I
started trying to do I was little I
started running away at 12. I was
singing a punk band at 12 open for DOA
when I was 12 years old I opened for the
sub-humans my very first show and then a
few months later I opened for DOA
um
and I've been in bands you know my whole
life and sitting around art I was living
on my own completely I went home and got
all my stuff and said buy a 14.
moving into the apartment downtown that
my guitarist
had a studio apartment our garage
apartment he said you can live here
downtown L.A this is in Houston yeah so
you can live here as long I I because he
stayed with his girlfriend as long as
you let me teach you algebra
which I found very odd very odd indeed
but then a few years later when I got a
full scholarship to Cornish Institute of
the Arts without ever going to high
school well I went seven days to high
school but um
and passed everything because I learned
Algebra I realized wow that was real
smart
yeah two years later I got that but um
um yeah I mean my childhood was I was
very free because I started babysitting
my brother and sister at eight years old
uh we were very poor and I was not
I was very much a misfit
when I moved to Texas I had to fit Cajun
accent and they tried to beat it out of
me put me in special classes teachers
use me example how not to speak so I
sucked myself into uh late night
television and Houston had these all
night movie channels that showed old
movies all night long you know a lot of
horror a lot of this and that sometimes
some great art films a Bicycle Thief I
saw you know when I was like eight on
but uh
I took the absence and the dialect and
the dialogue from those movies and sung
myself in that so I went from being
French [ __ ] to English [ __ ] and so on
and so on but I kind of I always won the
President's award and vocabulary every
year but it was because of TV people say
you can't TV is a bad babysitter but for
me it was
it was very good as far as learning how
to use the language and understand the
language which was you know part of you
know right I mean I sing I write lyrics
but it was an interesting childhood it
was a painful childhood I got introduced
to uh
I got handcuffed one time my
babysitter's uh nephew or
something was a security guard and he
handcuffed me one night and he told me
he wouldn't give me the keys so I drank
half a bottle of Jack Daniels
and I did and I think I was what seven
or so I drunk half a bottle of Jack
Daniels by myself
I think that was the first time I ever
drank
then I started selling I worked with
this Cruise selling papers scriptures he
used some posting Chronicle door-to-door
we'd go and sell subscriptions
and it was like a bunch of juvenile
delinquents in a van with a slightly
older juvenile delinquent in charge I
mean it was a lawsuit waiting to happen
if you piss if you did anything wrong
they did a wishbone on you they would
hold you down and beat you
there was sex going on you know uh it's
like this is giant lawsuit I can't you
couldn't get away with the stuff but
then you could and uh that's where I
first smoked pot and
people were taking acid and stuff I had
to take acid yet then but uh that was
kind of the drugs were seeping in
through the edges and of course hanging
out and I was hanging out with older
people a lot I mean starting from 12 I
hung out with like old New York Dolls
Glam rockers and these cast of Misfits
that were left over from the 70s that
were seeping that got into the punks the
new emerging Punk scene Punk was still
World freeform then it wasn't like the
hardcore Orange County Scene It was more
of a
it was more of an Arty weird crowd so I
remember being at parties and holding
off people as they were shooting up and
just talking blah blah blah and I was
like they treated me like I was a little
uh mascot because I was you know a 12
year old boy running away and I was very
androgynous and very cute so that made
very interesting times
um but yeah and uh that's why I got
picked the tag up David nobody because
uh no one knew my name and I wouldn't
let anybody know it and anything to do
with my former life
and there was uh one of the radio
stations had a a
they're showing the premiere of the punk
movie The DOA Punk movie with featuring
The Sex Pistols and there's a big
premiere on Halloween night and they had
the most Punk contest and it was all
these doctors and lawyers with garbage
bags and phone cords around their head
trying to think what they thought Punk
was and I was sitting in the back and I
was on a date with this girl the bass
player for the my dolls and interesting
enough she's a lesbian she didn't know I
was a boy
until we started making out when she
realized I was a boy and stopped the
date but uh
the the big singer Mike Hutchins who
later was in bands with me one of my
heroes and Ray Trejo the bass player for
a band called The bombers right up and
grab me by the arms lift me up over this
crowd and threw me on ran me to the
front and threw me on the stage I didn't
know what they were doing and I had my
Overcoat was filled with beer or
whenever I was grabbing him throwing
them put them back in screaming [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] and I won first place in
the most Punk contest
um and then I just I was out I was
living on my own and the world is my you
know it was all new and learning and
traveling but uh
the drugs kept coming in more and more
you know what year were you born I was
born in 1966 okay yeah okay yeah in
February I'm Aquarius
um
yeah I was uh and I was born in
Louisiana as I said raised up in Texas
uh I was a skateboarder I skated amateur
sponsored for zorlak I broke a lot I
hurt myself a lot a lot a lot of pain
and then um
but music started overriding that but
there was a lot of early injuries that
to this day Still Still troubled me not
bought in some of the pain medications
but uh I moved to Seattle in 19. I moved
I moved from Houston to Austin
right away and my girlfriend and I
her parents were wealthy they were they
owned an oil they built the pipeline her
father
um in Alaska and they had a big mansion
on Mount McKinley and I used to fly up
there and hang out and see her and then
she and I moved to Seattle in 83 and uh
you know that was from Austin to Seattle
very interesting move
um Seattle was still young it was still
dangerous in a water park town and it
felt it was just completely different
from Texas you got to wear black leather
all the time and
um and but Seattle had a heroin scene
you know whereas so much in Texas it's
there but it's not obvious you know but
in Seattle it was like everywhere there
were like heroin bars you know there was
bars downtown you walk in and the
bathrooms we'd go and they'd be like
what's up with these walls and you
realize they were covered in dried blood
from people just squirting syringes
they were like Korean Korean Mafia bars
or something it was like it was a whole
new world and it was very adventurous
but uh it was weird too because it was
also we were all so young and everybody
was so uh
innocent in a way but you're getting all
this stuff thrown at you you know it was
uh it was it was interesting I saw a lot
of people
I saw a lot of people uh
take steps towards their
their death or their demise then I saw a
lot of people take their step starts
being very rich rock stars too so
the drug use continued
yeah yeah I mean it wasn't like uh
it wasn't full on uh
um
being strung out all the time it was
more of like Adventures you know
but uh
it's it got a little more intense a
little more intense here and there uh
at the time it's funny too because I had
a you know I had a bet I had mini bands
uh but one of my bands we we pushed a
much greater drug use than we did it was
like kind of our thing was that we were
completely wasted all the time
and uh that built up a reputation
that was far more advanced than the
actual use was
people thought we were way worse than we
were and that kind of persisted
throughout my life there have been many
times when uh
I wasn't on drugs but people thought I
was and things were good as [ __ ] and it
was like okay might as well
they're always saying I am what's the
difference you know but uh in between
all that though I always had major you
know I did major things all the time uh
I always had this place I called my uh
future spot where I could see the Future
No Matter What was going on I knew the
next step of what was going to happen
uh that future spot kind of went dead
when Lisa killed herself
but uh yeah Seattle was a lot of fun it
was crazy I saw some you know some
tragedies but it was like I said it was
kind of innocent everybody's really
young and it was like discovering new
things of course there were old things
but new to us
um and it was the beginning you know
that whole scene exploded uh
you know I just happened to be I'd moved
from Austin and a great time and then I
moved to Seattle and a great time and uh
there was a lot of money going around
you know I could tell a lot of a lot of
stories about a lot of well-known people
that would get me in a lot of trouble I
won't do that
but yeah
um
in my life there's been times where I
pulled in and out you know I've like
ended up on the streets almost kind of
wanting to die
and then realizing I'm not going to die
and decide well I better get out of this
and then um
you know then like having a remarkable
you know
great career building opportunities you
know I've only I've not haven't owned
tattoo shops I've been working tattoo
shops partnered in tattoo shops
I've worked in the movie industry
I've uh you know I've changed every 10
years I seemed to change careers but
also there seems to be a great tragedy
that sends me back out on the streets
for a while
sometimes I think it's on purpose like
it's necessary to read
to learn something
um this last time has been really hard
though it's um
there hasn't been a lot of uh innocence
in
uh romance about it it's been um
it's been uh
quite the opposite
I didn't
um it's life-changing one of those
life-changing things where
you know just the wrong place the wrong
time the whole world changed
I got hurt really bad working on a
commercial
um
really bad I spent two months in the
hospital I had traumatic head injury
I see double out of one eye now I have
migraines and seizures I
had lost my uh my uh my debt perception
is really messed up
um like if I go to grab something I I'm
behind it I'm in front of it I if I put
my finger on a DOT and then close open
the other eye and close one I'm two
inches away from it
I my I left side of my body is badly uh
was badly torn and
anyways I'm I got really messed up and
I don't know if my former career if I
ever be if I'll be able to do that again
um and I'm fighting
uh workman's comp and there's lawyers
and it's just been this incredible
headache I've lost everything
[Music]
uh
and I'm basically living I went from
living in my car now I'm on the streets
and uh
I don't see that future spot anymore
you lost it you lost your car
it's not gone yet but it's a it's just
under a thousand dollars
uh someone
I got I pissed off some drug dealers and
gang members because I'm always trying
to fight Injustice and they decided to
put
to punish me and it's been a series of
fafs and trying to steal my car and one
thing they got was my all my paperwork
my registration and everything
so they if they stole my car that'd be
easy to sell but um
that when my car got towed they would
not let me do anything towards getting
it until I provided got all that stuff
again so it's just gone up I could have
had it the first day it was three 3 35
straight off the bat
but I had to recover I had to get all
that stuff again and I had to pay off
some things and do some things and so
now it's like right under a thousand
bucks
um so I don't know I'm still trying
but uh
it's gonna be hard
um
yeah so and also I'm
not I'm very very uh
depressed manic might be a good term for
it I've always been manic uh supposedly
I've been diagnosed is bipolar but um
living on the streets doesn't help that
no no and being robbed constantly not
having any place to keep anything
paperwork constantly gone I had the uh I
took the immobilizer for my car it's a
theft prevention device oddly enough and
I took it off because the car won't
start without it
and I keep it in my chest pocket and the
other night I fell asleep on the streets
I go days without sleeping I just walk
and walk it's so exhaust
but anyway I fell asleep and someone got
it
and it's really hard to find uh they
just I there's found two and there was
two in the U.S uh on Craigslist or I
looked up online I was finding it but uh
that's gone now so I can't drive the car
out a lot so that's going to be a big
problem
and I could bypass that but it's going
to take some work
um but anyway uh
yeah this has not been
you know my other Adventures is sad and
tragic as they were
there was something like you know
there was something kind of come from an
art uh writing lyrics uh I just felt it
was purpose this I have no idea what's
going on every day the obstacles just
get bigger
and bigger and every time I take a step
forward it's like a hundred steps back
and I have lost all faith and Humanity
I've seen things out there that are
unbelievable the cruelty that people the
cruelness of people and
the homeless Robin the homeless
you know you can't fall asleep out there
right now there's no you know
and it's a doggy I mean it's probably
always been like this and I mean I know
it's always been like this but somehow
I'm more on this time I'm just
it's way more brutal what is your drug
now
uh uh well whatever it has to be juggle
choice I say heroin but doesn't mean I'm
doing it it just means it would be my
drug Choice fennel uh well I have been I
got really sick I got E coli poisoning
and spent 14 days coming up both ends
and the only thing that would
stop it or slow it down was a hit of
Fentanyl
um Betty
so that was the introduction to uh to
that
cruel cruel substance
very scary it's like you taste it and
you're like I knew instantly
this is not good kicking this must be
horrible
uh the strength of it is is frightening
uh the variety of it is kind of scary
because if there's that you know
there's a lot of uh
I mean the difference in batches or
kinds and stuff is radical
yeah it's it's real weird but yeah
that's what uh that's been
coursing through my blood of light
it was a bigger factor in your current
situation the
abuse and the garbage you went through
as a kid or
the things that happen later in your
life
well what's weird and it probably you
can probably tell that the way I'm
talking is a lot of things are coming up
now from then
I was able to push all that aside or put
it away or not think about it but
for some I mean maybe it's I don't know
it's just that stuff seems to be hurting
me more now than it did back then
and uh
what was it what was it what was the big
what was that question again no just
asking if if the like the child abuse
the sexual abuse you went through as a
kid was a bigger factor in your current
situation or some of the setbacks you
had it okay well all that stuff all that
stuff I'm reviewing and it's coming
through way stronger than never did
before combined with what's going on now
I mean
I've spent a lot of life in the last
couple of DEC or a couple of decades
faking it till you make it sort of uh
putting on a mask and just going
hoping something kicks in and starts
working
and it does
now it's like
it's uh it's like I write these songs
and
I'm they're coming to fruition now I got
this I have this song I wrote for a long
time ago about being
comparing homeless to being a ghost
on the street
it's just like it's a combination of
that and it's [ __ ] I'm seeing and the
stuff I'm going through together
I just feel like I don't know I don't
see a lot of reason to put up with any
of it anymore you know it's like going
through these putting up this fight for
what what's the goal
and that
you know kind of promotes
numbing the mind
and I'm in a lot of pain
I hurt all over I woke when I woke this
morning
I hadn't done anything last night and so
it was you know I woke up pretty clear
and it was just
I wake up crying a lot if I'm in the
wrong position because my body's so torn
and broken
I was in the hospital for two months
from that accident and they kept me
there because they couldn't get my blood
rate or heart rate down
because the pain was so great and at
first they thought there was something
wrong with my heart and they did a lot
of tests and brought in a specialist and
turns out I have a great heart I have
like a really amazing heart
uh they showed me they had the uh really
fancy um
uh the thing you look at babies with but
um and my heart's great so the guy said
it's not your heart because you're in
that much pain
and they they decided that it's because
I've been through so much trauma and on
so much pain medication that my brain
just thinks it's pain medication is air
it's water it's just something I can
take constantly
and uh
so they put me on a ketamine drip
this experimental pain depression thing
and they put me on it for about a month
and uh it was just a big old giant bag
of ketamine going down a house into my
arm and after about two weeks it started
working the pain medication start
working what they said it was going to
do that my synopsis everything is just
it all needs a reboot they said my whole
system needs a reboot and they're hoping
that this is gonna
reboot me into working and it actually
did after about two weeks the pain
medication started working at least
enough for my heart rate to go down and
me to get
get released they want to put me in the
nursing facility for a while but the uh
the
workman's comp wouldn't have it
they wouldn't let it happen so I
they were going to keep me on that
ketamine as long as they could
um you know I thought it was crazy at
first but it was working
but yeah I it's a combination the the
stuff from the past and what I'm going
through now
and just the horror that I see on a
daily basis
and it's really scary out there is that
I'm watching kids who it used to take 20
years for people to enter that kind of
crazy screaming at the Moon psychosis
that you see
and I'm watching kids go into it in a
year two years I mean I'm watching young
people beautiful like healthy young
people
that are losing their minds and all I
could think it's the drugs
the drugs out there are really strange
there's no uh like fetty is different
like so very so much the fentanyl they
call it fetty
and the uh and you know most people are
smoking off an aluminum foil which isn't
good but uh and the speed now is so
weird like 20 years ago speed with speed
you know you had some different
varieties but it was speed now it's just
this mix like
I don't know what's going on but some of
the drugs that are out there are just
toxic you know if you try to inject it
uh
you get giant gaping sores that aren't
from missing it's just from the chemical
itself uh
yeah there's weird stuff going on I you
know some people think it's the
government experimenting trying with the
California's homeless you know there's a
big strong theory of that out there
um
and uh
you know every there are many theories
but
it's really weird I don't know I
I actually have probably
can become more conservative in how I do
drugs and the way I in what it with my
drugs that I used to be because I'm kind
of scared of what's out there now
um but anyway what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear
I was gonna say live in another 20 years
um
I think I'm not gonna get to die
I I'm gonna be an old man
um
my biggest fear is
living a boring mundane life
that was my first little kid and it's
still my fear the color brown
um Sandalwood
um
top uh top 40 radio my biggest fear is
probably
the my biggest fear is dying is living
in these streets for another 20 years or
10 years
I don't know I don't fear a lot
I did my oh I know what my biggest fear
is
you're getting not leaving something
good on this planet not doing something
that meant something that's my biggest
fear and that my name gets tainted
I fought long and hard to be a good
person to do the right thing I mean I
don't know what your opinion what your
opinion is of drug users but I don't Rob
people I don't steal
try not to lie usually only do it when
it's to save someone's feelings
uh my biggest fear is that my reputation
gets tainted
and that I
don't leave something
some kind of good Mark on the world
something meaningful something
meaningful yeah
I guess maybe that is yeah that I don't
get to live long enough to to do that
yeah
yeah I guess that's my biggest fear
yeah Emmanuel what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
uh
to trust my gut to go with my gut
did not overthink
and uh
don't let the bastards get you down
foreign
all right Emmanuel thank you so much for
sharing your story
I hope that worked it was interesting
I felt like it was going off more into
music than I'm not sure does it work for
you yeah it's excellent